MOTOR CALLED THE ARTS
ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS AND TOURS
AND AND INTERNET MEDIA COMEY HE
IN ORDER.
M. WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM NOW
BUT WE CAN START A SUBCOMMITTEE.
L. WE THE MEMBER ROMO SAYS HERE.
I'M.
ARE YOU READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE COME
[inaudible]
FOR THIS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT A AB.
TWO SEVENTY FIVE THE FIRST AYE
AYE WILL BE ACCEPTING TO
AMENDMENTS TO LEADING C. IN
SECTION EIGHTY TWO EIGHTEEN A
STRIKING THE PROVISIONS AND
FIFTY NINETY FOUR POINT NINE
FOUR AM.
IN A AS CHAIRMAN OF THE ASSEMBLY
SELECT COMMITTEE ON NATIVE
AMERICAN AFFAIRS FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND AS A FORMER CHAIRMAN OF THE
NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION.
WE CONTINUE TO SEE -- DIFFERENT
DIALOGUE THAT TAKES PLACE IN THE
DISCONTENT BETWEEN -- TRIBAL
ELDERS OF KNOWLEDGE BEING
RECOGNIZED.
IN THE DISCUSSIONS OF IN
RIVERTON DISCOVERY OF HUMAN
REMAINS.
IN AND WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS
AND DRAFTING A PLAN -- FOR THE
HERITAGE COMMISSION WE FOUND
THAT THERE CONTINUES TO BE A
SIGNIFICANT LACK OF TRIBAL AND
STAKEHOLDER KNOWLEDGE.
OF COMMISSIONS LAWS AS WELL AS
CONFUSION RESPECT TO THE
PROTECTION OF NATIVE AMERICAN
REMAINS AND CULTURAL ITEMS.
WHEN I WAS ELECTED TO THIS BODY
THE STATE LEGISLATURE IT'S A
PRIORITY FOR ME TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUES -- HIGHLIGHTED -- WITHIN
INDIAN COUNTRY DEALING WITH
THESE ISSUES.
AND SO MUCH SO THAT AB TWO
SEVENTY FIVE UPDATES CURRENT LAW.
WITH RESPECT TO THE POSSESSION
OF HUMAN REMAINS ITEMS BY
REQUIRING TRIBAL TRADITIONAL
KNOWLEDGE TO BE A FACTOR.
IN THE REPATRIATION PROCESS
CURRENTLY AT THIS TIME THE
TRIBAL KNOWLEDGE IS AT A LEVEL
HERE AND DEPARTMENT HEADS ARE
HERE AND WHEN THERE'S JUST
[inaudible]
THIS AGREEMENT.
THERE HAS TO BE THAT BALANCING
OF THAT TRIBAL KNOWLEDGE OF THE
CULTURE OF THE PEOPLE THE PEOPLE
ARE MAKING DECISIONS ON HERE
TODAY WITH ME AS I'M CHAIRMAN.
RAYMOND HITCHCOCK OF WILTON
RANCHERIA TO TESTIFY TO THESE
AREAS.
WHICH EXES COULD YOU HAMMER
HELLO GOOD DAY CHAIRMAN JUNE A
STEAM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AS A ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALMOST IT
SAID I'M REMAIN SEE HITCHCOCK
I'M OF ME WHAT CONDITION
UNDERSTAND.
I'M THE TRIBAL CHAIRMAN OF WHAT
RANCHERIA WERE THE ONLY
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBE HERE
IN SACRAMENTO AREA.
I WANT TO FIRST ACKNOWLEDGE AND
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER JAMES
RAMOS FOR HIS LEADERSHIP IN
INDIAN COUNTRY.
AND THE IS -- AUTHORING THIS AB
TWO SEVENTY FIVE LEGISLATION.
AS A TRIBAL CHAIRMAN OF WHAT
RANCHERIA IT IS MY DUTY TO LEAD
IN ASSIST OUR TRIBE
INTERCULTURAL DEPARTMENT. TO
ENSURE THE PROTECTION IN SACRED
SITES.
CULTURALLY SENSITIVE AREAS.
IN RESOURCES ANCESTRAL REMAINS
AND FUNERARY OBJECTS.
REPATRIATION OF ANCESTRAL
BELONGINGS THAT ARE UNDER DURING
DEVELOPMENT IN CONSTRUCTION.
AND UTILIZE THE CURRENT NATIVE
AMERICAN GRAVES PROTECTION AND
REPATRIATION ACT TO GET
COLLECTIONS BACK FROM STATE
AGENCIES IN MUSEUMS.
THAT ARE FROM OUR ANCESTRAL
TRIBAL TERRITORIES.
THIS BILL WILL HELP GIVE TRIBES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA MORE TOOLS
TO EXPEDITE THE SLOW AND TEDIOUS
NAG PER PROCESS.
AND ALLOW OUR UNIQUE TRIBAL
PERSPECTIVE ON TRIBAL
TRADITIONAL KNOWLEDGE TO CARRY
EQUAL OR GREATER WAY.
THE NON TRIBAL RESOURCES.
SOME BEHALF OF THE MEAL A
COMMISSION ON PEOPLE OF WILL
RANCHERIA AND OUR ANCESTORS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK AN AYE VOTE ON
AB TWO SEVENTY FIVE LEGISLATION.
THIS WILL STRENGTHEN OUR
GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
COMMUNICATION AND COLLABORATION
BETWEEN NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES
IN OUR STATE AGENCY COUNTERPARTS
ALIKE.
TING A COMMA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT PLEASE
COME.
FOR HI MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS --
BERRY BROKAW ON BEHALF OF THE
ABA KILEY ANTI BAND OF CAHUILLA
INDIANS IN PALM SPRINGS THE
OPERATORS OF A CULTURE MUSEUM
THAT'S AFFILIATED WITH THE
SMITHSONIAN INSTITUTE IN
WASHINGTON
GREAT BILL THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHRIS LUNCH
FROM CALIFORNIA TRIBAL BUSINESS
ALLIANCE REPRESENT PAULA BAND OF
MISSION INDIANS PICKING
RANCHERIA CHECK CHANCE INDIANS.
MENTORS MARTINEZ DESERT KEY
INDIANS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S AFFECT VARGAS FOR THE
RINCON BAND OF LOOSE INYO
INDIANS STRUCK SUPPORT ALSO
POINTING OUT THE CALIFORNIA
NATION'S ANY GAMING ASSOCIATION
SEE NIGHT AND SUPPORT.
THEM PROUD TO BE AFFILIATED WITH
THIS BILL IS A ENROLLED MEMBER
OF THE CLIMATE TRACK.
THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS FRANK BELLINO
BEHALF OF THE SAN MANUEL BAND OF
MISSION INDIANS IN THE SIGNING
IS BANNED UP TO MISSION ISN'T
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBER SILVIO FOR HERE
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION WE DON'T
HAVE A POSITION BUT WE WANT TO
COME THANK THE AUTHOR -- FOR THE
CONVERSATIONSWE HAD IN REMOVING
THE SECTIONS IN REGARDS TO SEE
CA.
WE ABSOLUTELY UNDERSTAND -- THE
IMPORTANCE OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING THEM AS WE MOVE FORWARD
THANK YOU.
ANY OF OF OPPOSITION WITNESSES
OF OPPOSITION.
SEEN ON ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
DAIS.
THANK YOU VERY SECOND.
ALL RIGHT.
YOU'RE VERY MUCH YOU KNOW WOULD
BURY PAUL -- FEW.
VERY PROUD OF IS -- WITH THE
REPRESENTATIVE THE FIRST -- AND
NATIVE AMERICANS YES SIR FROM
THE ASSEMBLY SO.
AND AND ON THIS ISSUE I THINK
YOU KNOW THE BEST YOU KNOW THAN.
TO ANYONE OF US SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
OVER.
UP AND ALSO THANK YOU FOR TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS SUGGESTED BY THE
COMMITTEE.
SOUNDS LIKE WE WILL HAVE A WE
WILL HELP THE OF A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
SO -- WOULD JUST HAVE TO WAIT
FOR THE WE HAVE A CORD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF A
COULD I DO HAVE THINGS WRITTEN
DOWN FOR A CLOSE BECAUSE THE
SAID GET THE GOVERNOR IS THAT
OKAY WITH YOUR YOU KNOW AND
REALLY JUST THE THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY -- TO NOW THAT
AND AND THE THE MOTION THE
SECOND -- SO QUICKLY ON IT WE WE
ARE -- IN A TIME TO WEAR.
TRIBAL ELDERS AND THEIR
KNOWLEDGE SHOULD BE RECOGNIZED
ESPECIALLY DEALING WITH --
INVERT DISCOVERY OF HUMAN
REMAINS AND IT'S THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE ORIGINAL PEOPLE CALIFORNIA
WITHOUT VOICES THERE AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND THANK
YOU THIS COMMITTEE AND HOPEFULLY --
WILL REQUEST AN AYE VOTE FROM
ALL MEMBERS AND THANK YOU FOR
MOVIE SO QUICK ON THE MOTION A
SECOND THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
[inaudible]
MR MAIENSCHEIN.
MR MAIENSCHEIN HAS TWO BILLS.
NOW WHICH ONE ARE YOU YOU WANNA
GO FIRST -- WHICH ARE WHEN YOU
WANT YOU WANT TO START WITH AB
THREE OH NINE SHOULD CHAIR.
THROUGH.
NINE ARI GREATLY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
POLICE CARS ARE IMPORTANT
ARTIFACTS THAT POLICE HISTORICAL
SOCIETY'S DUE TO THEIR THEIR
HISTORICAL SIGNIFICANCE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW IT IS ILLEGAL
TO POSSESS OR OPERATE A POST
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE VEHICLE
PAINTED TO RESEMBLE A POLICE
VEHICLE.
THIS RESTRICTION DOES MAKES ALL
POLICE VEHICLES FACING THEIR END
OF SERVICE TO BE SENT TO JUNK
YARDS ARE TO BE STRIPPED OF
THEIR EQUIPMENT ALONG WITH
MARKINGS.
AB THREE OH NINE WILL EXCLUDE
FEDERAL STATE OR LOCAL POLICE
MUSEUMS AND OTHER A HISTORICAL
pTHIS BILL WAS BROUGHT TO ME BY
THE SAN DIEGO POLICE HISTORICAL
ASSOCIATION -- BECAUSE THE SAN
DIEGO PD ONE TO DONATE A POST
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE CROWN
VICTORIA -- TO THE MUSEUM FOR
DISPLAY BUT ARE UNABLE TO DO SO
BECAUSE OF CURRENT LAW THIS BILL
IS ONLY INTENDED TO ALLOW FOR
DISPLAY AT MUSEUMS AND EVENTS
AND WILL NOT AUTHORIZE A
VEHICLES TO BE DRIVEN ON PUBLIC
ROADS.
UNLESS THEY'RE TRAVELING TO A
DISPLAY SITE OR OTHER AUTHORIZED
USE I'M HAPPY TO WORK WITH
COMMITTEE GOING FORWARD -- TO
ENSURE THE INTENT BILLS CLAIRE.
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AND I WROTE.
THANK YOU -- ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OF AB THRILL.
NINE PLEASE COME.
FOR GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
CELESTE WILD I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION MUSEUMS AND WE THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION MUSEUMS
PARTS THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEN ON ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
DEATH [inaudible]
GREEN NONE [inaudible]
YOU.
THE THE CHIEF IS STILL -- BILL
LANCE STORE.
NOW NOW NOW I KNOW WE I KNOW WE
TOOK HIM FROM YOUR CITY I GUESS
RIGHT RIGHT OKAY SO NOW RE YEAH.
WERE THANK TWO CHIEFS PASSED HIM
NOW.
WHILE A TIME FLIGHTS YEAH
DECIMATED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BRINGING THIS VIEW AT ALL OR
WE DON'T.
HAVE A CORN NOW [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY TILL WILL LET'S MOVE ON TO
THREE SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR AT AB
THREE SEVENTY NINE ADDRESSES AN
ISSUE THAT AFFECTS OUR YOUNG
ATHLETES SUDDEN CARDIAC ARREST.
THAT HAS EMERGED AS A LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH AMONG PEOPLE
UNDER TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF AGE
STUDIES SHOW THAT ONE IN THREE
HUNDRED YOU'D HAVE AN UNDETECTED
HEART CONDITION WHICH CAN RESULT
IN A POTENTIALLY FATAL OF THAT.
HI HOW ARE YOU THIS -- 72% OF
THOSE WHO SUFFERED AN EPISODE
DID NOT RECOGNIZE THE SYMPTOMS
AS LIFE THREATENING COACHES
PARENTS AND REFEREES ARE OFTEN
UNPREPARED WHEN.
SCA STRIKES 92% OF VICTIMS WILL
DIE IF NOT TREATED WITHIN
MINUTES CURRENT CONCUSSION
PROTOCOL REQUIRES A YOUTH
ATHLETE TO BE REMOVED FROM THE
ACTIVITY FOR THE REMAINDER OF
THE DAY -- AND SHALL NOT BE
PERMITTED TO RETURN UNTIL THE
ATHLETE IS EVALUATED BY A HEALTH
CARE PROFESSIONAL AB THREE
SEVENTY NINE WOULD REQUIRE THE
SAME PROTOCOLS USE FOR
CONCUSSIONS.
I TO BE USED WHEN SCA OCCURS
WITH ME TODAY.
I HAVE AT AS SEVERAL PEOPLE
MAUREEN WAG THE CO EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THEIR PAREDES SAVE A
LIFE FOUNDATION IN ERIC'S
PARENTS.
WHO HAVE WORKED ON THIS -- IN
SEEN DIEGO FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS --
AND HAVE DONE REALLY PHENOMENAL
WORK IF YOU'VE EVER BEEN OUT
THERE. TO SEE ONE WE'VE TESTED.
AT SCHOOLS IT'S REALLY A
REMARKABLE I GET THE THEY KNOW
THE EXACT SUGGEST EXPERT HOW
MANY WIVES WE'VE ALREADY SAVE A
HAS BEEN PHENOMENAL SOME REALLY
PLEASE YOU GUYS ARE HERE TODAY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THIS TIME.
AND COURSE ASSEMBLYMAN --
MAIENSCHEIN FOR SUPPORTING US MY
NAME IS HECTOR PRESS NINE BREAK
WILL BE HEARD TODAY.
BUT WHAT ABOUT WHAT WE KNOW IS A
LIFE OR DEATH ISSUE.
IN JUST A FEW WEEKS ON MAY THIRD
OUR SON ERIC WOULD HAVE BEEN
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OLD.
WE LOST HIM WHEN HE WAS JUST
FIFTEEN YEARS OLD TO AN
UNDETECTED HEART CONDITION THAT
STUDIES SHOW.
THAT ONE IN THREE HUNDRED YOUTH
AT RISK FOR SUDDEN CARDIAC
ARREST.
IN HIS MEMORY AND TO PROTECT
THEIR FAMILIES FROM THE TRAGEDY
OF LOSING A CHILD THE SYNDROME
THAT COULD BE PREVENTED.
WE FOUNDED THE AEROPRESS SAVE A
LIFE FOUNDATION.
ACROSS THE TEN YEARS SINCE WE'VE
LOST HIM.
OUR FOUNDATION HAS TOUCHED
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIA YOUTH PARENTS.
EDUCATORS SCHOOL NURSES COACHES
ATHLETIC TRAINERS AND COUNSELORS
WHO WORK WITH YOUTH BY ADVANCING
SUDDEN CARDIAC ARREST PREVENTION.
TO HELP PROTECT YOUNG HEARTS.
TWO YEARS AGO NEW PREVENTION
PROTOCOL WAS INTRODUCED TO
SCHOOL COMMUNITIES THROUGH AB
ONE SIX THREE NINE ALSO KNOWN AS
THE AEROPRESS SUDDEN CARDIAC
ARREST PREVENTION ACT.
THE NEW PROTOCOL MIRRORED
PRACTICES ALREADY IN PLACE TO
MITIGATE DAMAGE CAUSED TO
STUDENT ATHLETES FROM
CONCUSSIONS.
THIS WAS AN IMPORTANT ADDITION
TO SCHOOL SPORTS PROGRAMS
BECAUSE IN FACT SUDDEN CARDIAC
ARREST IS THE NUMBER ONE KILLER
OF STUDENT ATHLETES.
FOLLOWING THE SAME.
PATHWAY.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AB TWO ZERO
ZERO SEVEN EXTENDED CONCUSSION
PROTOCOLS TO APPLY TO COMMUNITY
SPORTS PROGRAMS.
AND NOW THE SAME REASONING WE
ARE ASKING TO EXTEND SUDDEN
CARDIAC ARREST PREVENTION
PROTOCOL. TO COMMUNITY SPORTS
PROGRAMS TO AB. THREE SEVENTY
NINE FOR PERSPECTIVE CONSIDER
THESE STATISTICS.
THERE ARE SIX POINT TWO MILLION
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA A SINGLE STUDY.
OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY YOUTH AGES
SIX TO SEVENTEEN FOUND THAT
EIGHTY TO PROTECT 82%.
PARTICIPATE IN A SPORTING
ACTIVITY ONE THIRD OF THOSE
ACTED ACTIVITIES HAPPEN TO
ORGANIZE NON SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
EXTRAPOLATED ACROSS THE STATE
THAT EQUATES TO MILLIONS OF
ACTIVE KIDS PARTICIPATING IN
COMMUNITY SPORTS PROGRAM.
WHICH MEANS THAT MILLIONS OF
KIDS ARE NOT BENEFITING FROM THE
PREVENTION OF PROTOCOL NOW IN
PLACE IN SCHOOL SETTINGS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WE HOPE
YOU'LL SUPPORT A. B..
THREE SEVENTY NINE YOU FOR
SHARING YOUR PERSONAL INSURANCE.
THANKS WITNESSES.
A GOOD MORNING -- HI MY NAME IS
WHEN A PREDICATE PER AT ITS
GRAYSON THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN.
INTO THIS COMMITTEE FOR GIVING
US A VOICE HERE TODAY.
WHILE MANY ARE NOT AWARE OF THE
REALITIES OF SUDDEN CARDIAC
CARESSING USE.
OUR COMMUNITY YES.
AND WE KNOW THAT WE ARE NOT
ALONE.
THE AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION
REPORTED LAST YEAR THAT APT TO
SIXTEEN THOUSAND YOUTH ARE
STRICKEN ANNUALLY.
THE RECENTLY RELEASED MEDICAL
EXAMINERS ARCHIVES IN SAN DIEGO
REVEALED THAT OUR COUNTY ALONE
HAS LOST AT LEAST TWELVE YOUNG
PEOPLE EACH YEAR.
BUT THE MOST IMPORTANT THING TO
UNDERSTAND ABOUT SUDDEN CARDIAC
ARREST IS THAT HE CAN BE
PREVENTED.
IF WE ARE PREPARED.
PREPARE TO RECOGNIZE POTENTIAL
WARNING SIGNS PREPARE TO RESPOND
TO A KARTIK EMERGENCY BY
PROVIDING IMMEDIATE ON SITE
INTERVENTION. 72% OF YOUTH WHO
EXPERIENCED SUDDEN CARDIAC
ARREST HAD AT LEAST ONE SYMPTOM
PRIOR TO THE EVENT.
THEY JUST DID NOT RECOGNIZE IT
AS BEING LIFE THREATENING.
THAT MEANS KIDS WILL FAINT WHICH
IS THE NUMBER ONE SIGN OF A
POTENTIAL HEART CONDITION OR
KIDS WHO EXHIBIT OTHER SYMPTOMS
THAT APPEAR TO BE.
CARDIOVASCULAR RELATED NEED TO
BE PULLED FROM PLAY IN SEEN BY A
DOCTOR.
NO DIFFERENT THAN THE EXISTING
CONCUSSION PROTOCOLS.
A SUDDEN CARDIAC ARREST VICTIMS
MUST RECEIVE HANDS ONLY CPR IN
AN EIGHTY D. SHOCK WITHIN FIVE
MINUTES OF COLLAPSE.
BUT SINCE THE AVERAGE EMS
ARRIVAL TIME IS EIGHT TO TWELVE
MINUTES PEOPLE ON SITE MUST BE
PREPARED TO INITIATE THIS
LIFESAVING PROTOCOL.
THIS IS WHY BYSTANDER
INTERVENTION IS SO IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IT CAN TRIPLE THE CHANCE
OF SURVIVAL.
AB THREE SEVENTY NINE INTRODUCES
THIS EDUCATION AND BEST PRACTICE
INITIATED BY THE ERROR PER THE
SUDDEN CARDIAC ARREST PREVENTION
ACT OF TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN INTO
OUR COMMUNITY SPORTS PROGRAMS.
WE ARE TRULY GRATEFUL FOR THE
RECOGNITION OUR CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE HAS GIVEN OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS TO IN
ENACTING SUDDEN CARDIAC ARREST
PREVENTION LEGISLATION.
BUT WE STILL HAVE SO FAR TO GO
IN THIS IS THE NEXT STEP.
IN THE NAME OF OUR BEAUTIFUL SON
ERIC IN ALL THE YOUNG PEOPLE WE
CAN'T NEEDLESSLY LOST WE URGE
YOU TO PLEASE ADVANCE ASSEMBLY
BILL.
THREE SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU.
BEFORE YOU -- FORWARD.
THAT WOULD HELP -- FORM.
THE WHITE HOUSE FOR CERTAIN.
KANSEN CHU HERE KANSEN CHU HERE
DEEP.
DEEP HERE DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
CHOICE HERE FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN
HERE KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
NEWS AREA.
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM.
SOME OF THE BILL [inaudible]
SECOND [inaudible]
GROUP.
I WILL COME OUT ANY ADDITIONAL
WITH A SYSTEM.
FOR ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
MIKE CHESSER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ATHLETIC TRAINERS ASSOCIATION CO
SPONSORING THE BILL AND PROUD TO
BE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MR TURN MEMBER SYLVIA SOLELY
SHAUN BEHALF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
ANY -- WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
TREE NONE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
DANCE.
PACKAGE CHOI.
THANK YOU CHAIR -- MEMBER MEANS
SHINE THANK YOU FOR INTRODUCING
THIS BILL -- THIS IS A SONG SO
VERY A QUICK CALL TO BE ALL --
WHEN NEW MANDATE THAT SUCH A
TRAINING?
I'M SURE THAT WILL SAVE A LOT OF
A POTENTIAL LIFE SO.
BUT THE I AM A LITTLE BIT
CONCERNED ABOUT THE HOW -- THE
PEOPLE ARE STAFF FOR RELATED.
ON THE TRAINING -- PA LIABLE.
WHEN NOT A CERTAIN UNFORTUNATE?
INCIDENT HAPPENED THIS -- THIS
SOME MANDATE THAT REQUIRES SO
UNLESS THE PERSON PARTICIPATED
IN CERTAIN ACTION BUT IT IT
COULD MISS FOR WHATEVER
CIRCUMSTANCES SAID AND THE BIG
COME.
MAY HOLD.
THE TRAINERS CELL WALL THE STAFF
MEMBERS AROUND WOULD BE LIABLE --
AND I CAN LET.
THE SPONSORS ANSWER I I GUESS
WHAT I WOULD SAY INITIALLY AS IT
WOULD BE.
THE THE STANDARD THAT THAT
CURRENTLY EXISTS THE THE EXTENT
OF LIABILITY OF AN ATHLETIC
TRAINER FOR EXAMPLE IS.
SET IN.
IN BOTH -- LEGISLATION AND IN
CASE LAW.
AND SO THIS FITS IN WITH.
THE STATUS OF WHERE THE CURRENT
LAW IS.
NUMBER.
EIGHT THIS PHARMACY.
ADDING A SUDDEN CARDIAC ARREST
TO PREVENTION AT BUT THE WE A
THIS IS A MODERATE AFTER WHAT
THE CONCUSSION.
A PREVENTION ACT YES OKAY WHEN
THAT WAS -- INTRODUCED A WAS THE
ANY.
THE CODE LAWSUIT INCREASE OR NOT
THAT I'M AWARE OF MISTER NOT
THAT I'M AWARE MISTER TRY.
NO I DON'T THINK TOO BECAUSE IT
IS ALL COVERED BY THE CUSTOMER.
GOOD GOOD SAMARITAN LAW GO.
OKAY THANK YOU HI GREG ABBOTT TO
SUPPORT [inaudible]
GREAT.
RIGHT.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- THE
MYSTERY MAN SHOWING FOR BRING
THIS BILL FOR AND THANK YOU FOR
TO A WITNESSES.
FOR SHARING YOUR PERSONAL --
EXPERIENCE WAS WITH US SORRY
ABOUT THE LOSS OF YOUR SON.
AND THE DO JUST ONE QUICK
QUESTION AYE AYE WHEN I WAS ON
THE CELL THE CITY COUNCIL I
HELPED SOME.
OF THE OF A CITY ORDINANCE TO
REQUIRE EVERY OF HIGH RISE
BUILDING TO HELP ADD DEVICE OFF
EVERY OTHER FLOOR.
BUT BEFORE THE HOUSE ONLY HAVE
ONE AND IN THE LOBBY AND THAT'S
ANYTHING HAPPENS ON THE UPSTAIRS.
IS DIFFICULT FOR FOR THE TO
GIVEN THE FIRST RESPONDER TO GO
DOWN TO THE BASEMENT OR THE
LOBBY TO GET IT YOU DO TWO
FLIGHTS.
AND SOUGHT I HAD THAT
REQUIREMENT AND ALSO A
REQUIREMENT FOR ALL THE SCHOOL
GYM TO YOU COULD LIST THREE AG
DIVIDE.
US.
LEARN AT THAT TIME TO EIGHTY
DEVICES TO PASS -- TO TO TO TO
TO HELP TO A CAR DEAL A REST BUT
HOW HOUSES IF YOU ARE BEING VERY
EFFECTIVE.
CPR Là IS ON THE CPR IS A RAGE
TO LIFE.
CPR IS THE BRIDGE TO LIFE UNTIL
THE E. D. GETS TO WORD IT'S
NEEDED SO THE EIGHTY IS THE ONLY
TOOL THAT WILL RESTART THE HEART
YOU CAN DO CPR.
FOR JUST KEEPING THIRTY MINUTES
AN HOUR BUT IT'S NOT GOING TO
REALLY RESTART THE HEART SO WE
NEED THAT EIGHTY SO I THINK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BEING SO PROACTIVE.
IN HAVING THOSE EIGHTIES.
THANK YOU JUST MENTIONED.
I WOULD LIKE TO BE A A CO AUTHOR
OF COURSE STILL AND WORK WITH
YOU NEXT YEAR TOO AND THE FREE
REQUIRED YELL ALL THE SPORTS
LEAGUE TO HALF THE SUIT.
IS FUNNY I DID ON WHY THE SAME
BILL UP WHEN I WAS ON THE SAN
DIEGO CITY COUNCIL IT'S FUNNY
YOU SAY THAT ITEMS THE SAME
THANKS OUR WITH THAT DATA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- THANK YOU
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
PLEASE CALL.
AB THREE SEVENTY NINE
MAIENSCHEIN.
DO YOU PASSED TO THE ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING KANSEN CHU.
KANSEN CHU EYEING TEAM.
DEEP I DAVID CHIU [inaudible]
CHOI.
CHOI AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I MS ARIAN [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
CORRECT GRATEFUL HEART WILL WILL
LEAVE FOR THE ROLE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS ARE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
YOUR LIFE YOU MISTER DIEGO.
WITH HOME FOR DEPLORES YOURS.
WILL BE PRESENTING A. B. ONE
SOMEONE. FOR TWO SEVENTEEN FORTY
TWO CYCLE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THANK
YOU.
FOR YOU FOR MOVING THE BILL I
REALLY APPRECIATE THIS THIS IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT LOOK IT GOES
WITHOUT SAYING -- TO BE ABLE TO
APPROPRIATE FOR MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE KOREAN AMERICAN NATIONAL
MUSEUM -- IS SIGNIFICANT I MEAN
THIS THIS WILL HELP US TO
HIGHLIGHT HOW IMPORTANT -- THE
CREAM COMMUNITY HAS BEEN ON NOT
ONLY IN LOS ANGELES BUT ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND IT'LL HELP THE HIGHLIGHT --
THE INFLUENCE IN THE HISTORY OF
THOSE FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE HERE WHO LIVE.
IN CALIFORNIA OF KOREAN DESCENT --
I REPRESENT PRETENSE NO SECRET
TO ANYONE -- BUT I I I I BET YOU
DID THAT IF YOU REPRESENT ANY
DISTRICT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THIS BILL IS AS
IMPORTANT TO ME I'M SORRY
SUPPORT YOU.
AS IT IS IMPORTANT TO ME AND AND
WITH THAT I HAVE ONE WITNESS.
THANK YOU PLEASE.
WELL THANK YOU OF GERMAN TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS OF FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME BEFORE YOU
HERE TODAY.
MY NAME IS JOHN LIMóN AND ONE
OF THE EIGHT VOLUNTEER BOARD
MEMBERS OF THE KOREAN AMERICAN
NATIONAL MUSEUM.
A PUBLIC BENEFIT NONPROFIT
CORPORATION.
I'M BASED IN LOS ANGELES A AND
WORK WITHIN THE FIFTY THIRD
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
AND SO MY SPECIAL THANKS TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO. FOR
NOT ONLY OFFERING THE BILL BUT
ALSO FOR WONDERFULLY CIRCULAR
DISTRICT.
UP PLEASE ALLOW ME TO PROVIDE
YOU WITH A BRIEF BACKGROUND ON
OUR ORGANIZATION.
AND ITS MISSION TO SERVICE THE
ONE AND ONLY.
NATIONAL MUSEUM DEDICATED.
TO ASSEMBLING COMPILING
RECORDING AND ENRICHING.
THE HISTORY OF KOREAN AMERICANS.
BUT IT'S BEEN OVER HUNDRED
FIFTEEN YEARS SINCE -- KOREAN
AMERICANS BEGAN.
IMMIGRATING TO OUR GREAT NATION.
AND IT IS WIDELY BELIEVED --
THAT THE POPULATION OF KOREAN
AMERICANS EXCEED TWO MILLION.
MORE THAN A QUARTER OF THEM.
OF MAKE CALIFORNIA THEIR HOMES
IN ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF THOSE
KOREAN AMERICANS RESIDE IN.
THE LOS ANGELES AREA.
SO OUR LOCATION WHICH IS THE
SOUTHWEST CORNER VERMONT AVENUE
AND SIX STREET.
IS IDEAL AND WILL TRACK NOT ONLY
ANGELENOS.
BUT TOP TOURIST FROM OTHER
STATES IN FOREIGN COUNTRIES AS
ONE OF THE LEADING.
POINTS OF INTEREST IN LA.
OR FACILITY DESIGN THE DESIGN OF
WHICH IS ACTUALLY CONTAINED IN
THE PRESENTATION MATERIAL I'M
NOT SURE IF YOU RECEIVE THEM.
BUT WE CERTAINLY HAVE THIS
AVAILABLE -- IT CONSISTS ABOUT
SIXTEEN THOUSAND SQUARE FEET OF
INTERIOR SPACE FOR GALLERIES AND
DISPLAYS.
ARCHIVES.
ASSEMBLY AREA AND ADMIN OFFICE
AND OTHER SPACES REQUIRED TO
OPERATE THE MUSEUM.
ANOTHER TEN THOUSAND SQUARE FEET
OF SPACE IS BEING DEDICATED FOR
CREAM GARDEN.
THAT WILL PITIFULLY EXEMPLIFY
THE GRAYSON CREAN LANDSCAPING
WONDERS.
YOU WOULD.
OTHERWISE SEE ONLY IN KOREA.
IN SHORT.
WE BELIEVE THAT WE CAN
DEMONSTRATE TO THE WORLD.
THAT THE CONTRIBUTION KOREAN
AMERICANS HAVE MADE TO OUR
NATION.
IN ALL ASPECTS OF AMERICAN
CULTURE.
AND THAT THE KOREAN AMERICANS
CULTURE IS INDEED A VITAL PART.
OF THE FABRIC OF THE AMERICAN
CULTURE.
SO IT'S UNDISPUTED THE KOREAN
AMERICANS HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTIONS IN THE U. US.
IN VARIOUS FEELS YOU KNOW
SCIENCE EDUCATION MEDICINE LAW.
ENGINEERING RELIGION BUSINESS
BOTH SMALL AND LARGE.
AND MORE RECENTLY IN POLITICAL
LEADERSHIP S. DEMONSTRATED BY
THE PRESENCE OF ASSEMBLYMAN CHOI --
AND OTHERS WHO HAVE PROCEED.
THESE CONTRIBUTIONS MUST BE
CELEBRATED NOT ONLY BY THE
KOREAN AMERICANS FOR GENERATIONS
TO COME BUT ALSO BY.
ALL OF US AS A SOCIETY.
AS AS WE AS A SOCIETY COME TO
APPRECIATE THE STRENGTH AND
VALUE THAT ONLY DIVERSITY OFFERS.
OUR CREATE AMERICAN NATIONAL
MUSEUM WILL CON CONTRIBUTE TO
THAT DIVERSITY.
AND SERVE AS A PLATFORM FOR THE
CONTINUOUS CELEBRATION OF OUR
DIVERSITY.
THE CURRENT STATUS OF THE
PROJECT THIS IS AS FOLLOWS.
WE HAVE A OF RAN FREE GROUND
LEASE FOR THE SITE.
FROM THE CITY OF LA FOR TERM
FIFTY YEARS.
THE TOTAL PROJECT COST IS ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
AND WE HAVE TWELVE MILLION IN
COMMITTED FUNDS.
AS OF TODAY.
A FROM OUR DONORS THE SOME ALSO
INCLUDES THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION FORGIVABLE LOAN FROM THE
CITY OF LA.
THE REPAYMENT WHICH CAN BE MADE
BY OPERATING COMMUNITY SERVICES.
SO IT'S IT'S AFFECTED ME A GRANT
UP WITH THE SUBJECT FOUR MILLION
APPROPRIATE A GRANT FOR THE
MUSEUM WE WOULD NEED TO SECURE
ADDITIONAL NINE MILLION IN
FUNDING.
WE'RE CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN
SECURE THAT.
AT LEAST ONE HALF OF THE FROM
NEW CAM DONATIONS AND THE
BALANCE FROM A CONSTRUCTION LOAN
[inaudible]
SO.
OUR OUR OUR TIMELINE IS TO BREAK
GROUND IN SPRING OF TWENTY
TWENTY AND OPEN.
THE MUSEUM AND FALL OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SO IN CLOSING I WANT
TO THANK YOU.
ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF THE
MUSEUM.
AND STE AND ALSO ON BEHALF ALL
THE AMERICANS AT LARGE. TO BE
INVITED TO OUR BELOVED CUTTING
CEREMONY IN DUE TIME.
ALL RIGHT ALSO VERY MUCH IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS I'D LOVE TO
ADDRESS THE ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
MY NAME IS STEVE KING OF WITH
THE CREE TOWN YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY CENTER WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OF WITNESSES ST IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTION FROM
THE DAIS OR COMMON.
DOCTOR CHOI.
PAUL YOU KNOW I WELL WANTED THIS
IN NEW YORK -- I I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET THE BRIEFING
NOW FROM -- STEVE CAN NOW FROM
LOS ANGELES HE MADE THE TRIP
DOWN TO MY DISTRICT OFFICE AND I
TALKED ABOUT THIS OF PROGRESS ON
AND THE INTENDED THAT.
TO MAKE A PRESENTATION TO THIS
COMMITTEE IT TODAY AND I'M I
THANK YOU -- ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SANTIAGO FOR REPRESENTING --
KOREA TOWN IN LOSS AND LOS
ANGELES AREA SO WELL AND MAKING
THIS A PROPOSAL.
OF FOR A KOREAN -- NATIONAL
MUSEUM WHICH IS -- VERY VERY
IMPORTANT STUFF IT IS -- READ
THE THE LADY THE PROJECT --
SINCE -- NINETEEN OR THREE
KOREAN -- MASS.
IMMIGRATION IS STARTED.
NOW WHAT THEY'RE ALL.
OF WHAT THE OVER THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND NOW.
A KOREAN RESIDENTS THAT LIVE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BUT THE SOME
ESTIMATE DIFFERENT MORE NUMBER --
ECONOMICALLY -- POLITICALLY
CULTURALLY KOREANS HAVE WORKED
TO SO HARD.
AND I MYSELF I EVEN WONDERED --
NALA I AM GETTING H. SO ON MY ON
EFFECTS OF OVER TWENTY ONE YEARS
SO FOR MY POLITICAL ACTIVITIES
THAT THERE MAY BE SOME VALUE AND
A WHAT DO I DO WITH THAT -- ALL
IN MY GARAGE AND THE WALLS ARE
LOOKING FOR WHAT THE PLEASE TAKE
SOME THIS WAS A VERY WELCOME.
JUST IN TIME BEFORE I PASSED
AWAY.
SO A NEW IN -- I AM SO EXCITED I
HOPE THAT THE MEMBERS SO WE'RE
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND WHEN IT
COMES TO THE POINT THAT WE CAN
DO.
UPON BREAKING AND THE GRAND
OPENING NOT RP SO EXCITED JUST
TO BE PART OF THAT THE WITH THAT.
IF I CAN ASK A ON MY COLLEAGUES.
MR MANUKA THE SAN DIEGO -- TO A
COME.
OUT ADD ME IT HAS SUCH DON'T
ALSO.
ARE VIA REALLY ON UP.
MAY I RESPOND.
THANK YOU UP LOOK I BE HAPPY TO
HAVE YOU JOIN -- I I JUST NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT IS A
COMMITMENT TO WORK AS HARD AS
WE'RE GONNA WORK ON AND THEN
SHOW CALIFORNIA THIS COULD BE A
TRUE BIPARTISAN EFFORT -- WE
HAVE -- BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE
WORKING REALLY HARD FOR
SOMETHING THAT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT -- FOR CALIFORNIA BUT
YOU COULD DO THAT WE'RE GOOD.
OKAY THANK YOU YEAH ONE OF THE
COMMENTS SO HE ARE REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS COMMENT THIS SO ONE SIDED.
SO THAT'S WHY THIS BILL WILL
HELP ON THE FLOOR THAT'S MISTER
MISTER.
MAVERICK YES FIFTH.
LOVE Là I I THINK I THINK
TEMPORE BOTH LIKE TO FIGHT
REALLY HARD FOR THIS.
SO WOULD YOU.
ACCOUNT.
A CUP ACCOMMODATE.
OF ME HAS US DOING BOTH THE WITH
YOU -- I SAID YES TO LONG AS
BOTH SIDES FIGHT REALLY HARD FOR
THIS OUR THANK YOU SO IT'S A
COMMITMENT TO HER YEAH SO I
HEARD.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
OFFERING THIS FORWARD.
I'M VERY PROUD TO REPRESENT A
VERY LARGE -- COMMUNITY OF
KOREAN AMERICANS IN MY DISTRICT
AND I'VE BEEN ABLE TO TRAVEL TO
CREATE NOW THREE TIMES.
ADVISED US HOME CITY OF GLENDALE
HAS. TWO SISTER CITIES AND THREE
FRIENDSHIP CITIES IN KOREA AND
WHAT I LEARNED WHEN I WAS THERE
IS ABOUT THE VERY DEEP TIES
BETWEEN THE KOREAN PEOPLE AND
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND REALLY HOW MUCH PRIDE THERE
IS IN THAT RELATIONSHIP AND I
THINK THAT THAT'S A STORY THAT'S
DEFINITELY WORTHY OF BEING TOLD
AND OF INVESTING IN AND THAT
WILL ONLY STRENGTHEN.
THE BOND BETWEEN OUR NATIONS SO
I THANK YOU.
FOR THE WORK THAT YOU'RE BOTH
DOING ON THIS -- IMPORTANT
PROJECT AND I'D ALSO LOVE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR AND I DO
PROMISE TO WORK WITH YOU THAT'S
THE VERY HARD I NEED -- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE ONLY COMMUNITY
YOUR CARD YOU'RE ON ALL RIGHT
SOME OF THE MEMBERS CHAU.
I'LL JUST BE VERY BRIEF -- I AM
NOT JEALOUS ABOUT -- LA WITH
REGARDS TO MOST THINGS BUT WITH
REGARDS TO THE CREAM COMMUNITY
IN LA I AM.
REPRESENTING A CITY THAT HAS.
MANY SIGNIFICANT ASIAN
COMMUNITIES BUT WE DON'T HAVE
THE NUMBERS THAT -- THAT LA DOES
NOT REALLY APPRECIATE -- THE
AUTHORED.
FORM ALSO HAPPEN TO BE ADDED.
AS A A CO AUTHORED ANY LEVEL
THAT IT'S HELPFUL -- AND AS
CHAIR OF THE API CAUCUS -- JUST
REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK YOUR
BILL TO IN ON THIS.
THE ANSWER'S YES WITH A
COMMITMENT WORK HARD TO GET IT
DONE.
THANKS THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH --
I'LL DEFINITELY WOULD BE
SUPPORTING THE THIS BILL AND
WILL LOVE TO ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR.
A JUST A QUESTION TO THE WITNESS
AS YOU SAID OR TWO THIRDS OF THE
KOREAN.
IN CALIFORNIA LIVE AND THEY EL
áREA THE GREAT A LOS ANGELES IS
THE GREATER LOS ANGELES
INCLUDING GLENDALE.
AND I'M A PART OF THE IDEA
IRVINE AS WELL.
OKAY I JUST WILL DOUBLE CHECK
WAS OUR NUMBER.
BECAUSE I KNOW ONE THIRD OF THE
KOREAN AMERICAN IN CALIFORNIA I
LIVE IN MY DISTRICT.
AND THE THAT AS AS A NEAR THE
CITY OF SANTA CLARA SO I AM
ACTUALLY NOT SURE ABOUT OR
BUYING.
BUT IT FOR SURE ON PLAN THAT
WOULD BE PART WILL MAYBE. TWO
THIRDS MINUS ONE HELLO FROM
WHITE HALEY A THAT WOULD WORK
FOR ME TO HAVE ONE AND AND IT
LOOKS IN.
ORANGE COUNTY OF BRING TO SO
RIGHT YEAH FOR THE RECORD --
CITY OF IRVINE IS A SECOND OUR
LARGEST THOUGH -- A KOREAN --
MINORITY GROUP BUT AFTER CHINESE --
AND THEN ALSO.
I SHOULD.
KNOW BUT NO I IT WOULD OF
GUESSED THAT THE MINIMUM ONE
MINORITY GROUP BUT IN FULLERTON.
AREA SO -- ORANGE COUNTY SO VERY
STRONG YOU REPRESENTED ALL RIGHT
ALL WILL GET THE RECORD STRAIGHT
[inaudible]
LATER BUT I JUST LEGAL ONE AT
LEAST ECHO THE COMMENTS THAT
WERE SHARED AND AM IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AS WELL AND
WOULD LOVE TO THEM.
BE A CO AUTHOR AS WELL BECAUSE
WE HAVE A AMAZING POPULATION OF
KOREAN AMERICANS IN THE FIFTY
FOURTH AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE CULTURE AND
HISTORY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SHOULD DO WE
HAVE A MOTION.
AND THE SECOND.
ALL RIGHT GREAT.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY TWO SANTIAGO
DE PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS KANSEN CHU BY
KANSEN CHU ÁI.
DEEP.
DAVID CHIU.
DAVID CHIU AYE CHOI.
CHOI I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN NINE COMMA DEAF.
HI MARGARETHE I BILLS THANK YOU
BECAUSE THE COMMITTEE YOU'LL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN. FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER.
ALL RIGHT WILLOWS.
LIVE TO CALL ON AB.
TWO SEVENTY FIVE MAYBE TWO
SEVENTY FIVE RAMOS [inaudible]
AMENDED -- SACRAMENTO. TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
[inaudible]
KANSEN CHU.
I KANSEN CHU <c.cyan>WI DEEP.</c>
DAVID CHIU.
DAVID CHIU AYE CHOI.
CHOI I FRIEDMAN.
I COM MARGARITA.
KAMAGRA DEV I THIS AREA.
AB THREE THE ROLE.
NINE AB THREE SIX ZERO NINE
MAIENSCHEIN DO YOU PASSED TO THE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING KANSEN
CHU HI KANSEN CHU <c.cyan>WI DEEP.</c>
DAVID CHIU DAVID CHIU AYE CHOI.
CHOI I FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I CALM
WATER DOES.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I MISS AREA.
MARIE MOVE ON TO AB.
THREE SEVENTY NINE AB THREE
SEVENTY NINE MAIENSCHEIN DO YOU
PASSED TO THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING.
CHOI I'M SORRY -- DAVID CHIU
DAVID CHIU AYE COMODIDAD.
KAMAGRA DEATH HI THIS AREA IN.
ALL RIGHT AB IS. SEVENTEEN FORTY
TWO WE HAVE A PAPER HAVE RIPPED
EVERYTHING HOW BOTH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SEVENTEEN FIFTY FOUR
WHAT THAT TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR OKAY AND NOW CONSENT
CALENDAR.
KANSEN CHU I KANSEN CHU <c.cyan>WI</c>
[inaudible]
EIGHTEEN DAVID CHIU.
DAVID CHIU AYE CHOI.
CHOICE I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I HI MARGARETHE.
A MARGARITA I ALL RIGHT WE WILL
LEAVE THE ROOM OF THE ROLE OF
HIM FOR FIVE MINUTES.
THANK YOU MEMBERS
.
THERE YOU GO OKAY.
CALENDAR [inaudible]
AREA
AB.
SEVENTEEN FORTY TWO DEEP
SANTIAGO DEEP.
I ALL RIGHT READING THROUGH
JOINT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT BACK MODE.
GO BY ABOUT GO BACK.
A LOT -- YES.
THE NATIONAL.
YEAH. FOR CALLING UP THERE.
OKAY [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
RAY.
WILL NOT -- WOULD WOULD TAKE
CARE OF YOU.
WELL WE HELP YOU AND SO YOU